how to become a model that's the most
asked question I got on my channel and
it's time to tell you guys so let's get
into the video mistakes but mistakes
make you strong hey guys if you're new
here on my channel welcome to D LM model
lifestyle I'm Daniel and I've been an
international male model for over 12
years now if you don't want to miss the
next video click the subscribe and the
notification bell
alright so how do you become a mom well
first you need to know that there are a
few different types of models out there
I also talked a little bit about this in
one of my other videos check it out so
just to recap if you want to be a model
there are options number one social
media Instagram Facebook YouTube you
don't need to be very tall to be a
social media kind of model number two
fitness models fitness models there's no
hide requirements so you can be very
short but you have a amazing body and
then you can be a fitness model alright
number three
plus-size model as well just be
plus-sized and then the last one the
commercial models and a high-fashion
models yes those models need to be a
little bit taller with the commercial
model so you can be a little bit shorter
if you have a good face and a good body
but with the high-fashion model there's
no leeway there for fashion shares and
to be a high fashion model you need to
be taller alright so how can you become
a model if you fit the requirements well
there's basically two ways number one is
you get scouted by a model agency or a
scout the second way is that you contact
the model agency yourself so
do that so first you need to take your
measurements your length and yes there's
been a lot of guys that ask me hey do I
need to take off my shoes if I take my
length yes you do
all right so take your length then you
also need to take measurements off your
chest and your hip size those three
should be fine then you need to take
some snapshots as well so all you got to
do is to take some photos of yourself in
front a clean background preferably
white all right applause you have to
where is black fitted clothing or if you
don't have black just get some other
clothing that are neutral colors all
right then what you do is you take a few
photos off full-length forty five to one
side to the camera and 45 to the other
side then you come up and you get closer
shots of your face all right
the same put it back to one side to the
camera and 45 then you can do a few
extra shots we just show you expressions
from a little bit smile just so that it
can see a little bit of what you can do
all right but that's it for the photos
all right and once you've got that done
do it a little bit of research go on
internet check out the model agencies in
your area and then you send your
material up to them then all you got to
do is wait for the response now some of
them will say no some of them will say
well they'd probably probably ask you a
few questions and then another response
is yes can we see you for an interview
now a very important thing don't just go
to see one agency and sign with them if
you got a response from two three or
four agencies go and see all of them
before you make your decision so then
all you need to do is go in and see the
agencies all right don't stress too much
just relax and we're slim for the
clothes preferably black all right
don't try to impress them too much by
over dressing all right just look
healthy and natural first they'll ask
you a few questions just to see your
type of personality as well if they like
your look and if they need your look in
their agency they will ask you to join
them but remember don't just join them
wait a little bit go and see the other
agencies and then make your decision
lastly you also need to know the
difference between a normal agency and a
mother agency so what is a mother agency
a mother agency they're the ones that
manage your international career they
also take 10% of all the money that you
make if you're in another country so how
do you find a mother agency well any
normal agency can actually become your
mother agencies but you need to find out
if they have good international
connections before you sign with them so
just keep that in mind as well now let's
say you went you saw your agencies and
you're happy with one and you're like oh
I felt very comfortable with that then
join it but when you sign a contract
read the whole contract through don't
just sign anything all right
and don't make them your mother agency
first right just wait a little bit
and then when you're a happy later on
then you ask them hey guys because you
got to be my mother agency now some very
important tips number one
don't just trust any model agency out
there there's a lot of fake agencies and
there's a lot of agencies that you just
cannot trust do your research one of the
most asked questions I get is do you
need to go to a modeling school to
become a model short answer no you don't
need a modeling school to become not a
temp specially for your girls out there
no you never need to take naked photos
of yourself and send it to an agency if
they ask you that then you already know
they are not the real agents
now if you do become a model and once
you start working remember you don't
have to feel pushed into any type of job
that you don't feel come forward even if
you go to the job and I want you to do
something you can say no the last thing
modeling is not as easy as people think
it is it's changed a lot over the years
and it's become very difficult to make
money a lot of modeling there are loads
of model agencies out there and there's
loads of models out there as well so
there's a lot of competition for all the
jobs some models make no money
some just break even and there's a few
that makes a living of it but I can't
tell you and say yes you are gonna make
a success out of your modeling career
this is no way it depends on so many
factors most of all it depends on you
now if you're serious if you think that
you've got what it takes to become a
successful model check out my new
modeling book in every description down
below it'll answer a lot of questions
that you might have if you liked the
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
I'll see you in the next video Cheers
[Music]